Of all the actors who came of age in the '80s,
few seemed as destined for superstardom as
Rebecca De Mornay.
Her wit, humanity, and charisma seemed to
put her a cut above her contemporaries, but
where did her career end up taking her?
While she never reached superstar status,
you've probably seen more of her than you
realize.
De Mornay got her foot in the door of Hollywood
with a minor role in 1981's One From the Heart
— a musical romance from director Francis
Ford Coppola.
If you haven't heard of it, it's probably
because it hasn't held on in pop culture like
some of the director's other movies, such
as The Godfather, Apocalypse Now, or…
Jack.
But it was still a strong start for De Mornay,
who followed up her debut with a breakout
lead role in Risky Business.
That movie, a legit '80s classic, practically
made an icon out of her co-star, fellow up-and-comer
Tom Cruise.
If you're totally unfamiliar, Risky Business
is a classic coming-of-age tale where boy
meets girl… except the girl is a mysterious
prostitute and the boy is an inexperienced
suburbanite.
The two meet when Cruise's questionable decision
making skills land him in serious financial
straits, forcing him to find a unique way
to make a lot of money in a short amount of
time.
The result is a comedy about a homegrown brothel
that somehow stays charming, despite the sleaze.
The movie made Cruise an overnight superstar
and marked De Mornay as an instant "it girl."
But while Cruise's star power continued to
grow, De Mornay's new status proved a little
bit harder to hold on to.
After Risky Business, De Mornay's career took
off.
She followed her breakout film with a supporting
turn in 1983's Testament, but her stardom
took a serious hit in 1985 with the poorly-reviewed
baseball rom-com The Slugger's Wife.
You can't blame her for jumping onto a film
written by Neil Simon and directed by Hal
Ashby it just didn't work out.
Luckily, De Mornay kept her footing with a
pair of solid supporting turns in 1985.
The first — a heartfelt drama called The
Trip to Bountiful — found her sharing scenes
with screen legend Geraldine Page in a movie
that got attention from the Oscars.
The other, Runaway Train, is more of a pulse-pounding
crowd-pleaser, with the actress as a railroad
employee working to thwart two escaped convicts
that have sabotaged a train.
Despite having a story by Akira Kurosawa and
earning three Oscar nominations, the movie
is now often overlooked.
But it was impressive at the time, and helped
keep De Mornay's career chugging right along.
In 1986, De Mornay caught a ride with the
rock band Starship.
Specifically, she co-starred in the music
video for "Sara,"
The song was one of the most successful tracks
of the year, climbing the charts to hit number
one on the Billboard Hot 100.
De Mornay appeared in the video for the shamelessly
schmaltzy song alongside Starship singer Mickey
Thomas, telling a story about a dissolving
relationship.
Despite its contemporary success, the song
doesn't get much play anymore, but at least
it hasn't become as hated as "We Built This
City" did.
Though the 80s started strong for her, De
Mornay spent the second half of the decade
starring in projects that ranged from questionable
to downright abominable.
These movies included And God Created Woman,
Feds, and Dealers, but the worst one was 1987's
mind-bogglingly bad version of Beauty and
the Beast.
On paper, it doesn't sound so bad.
The movie was one of only a few English-language
adaptations of the classic fairy tale, and
the first to come up with the idea of turning
it into a musical, beating Disney to the concept
by a full five years.
John Savage was cast to play the Beast to
De Mornay's Beauty, but neither was served
well by the finished product.
The movie was criticized for being half-hearted
and uninspired, with less-than-stellar make-up
effects and unmemorable music.
The actors deserve credit for performing the
songs themselves, but it was ultimately a
risk that didn't pay off.
Hitting a backdraft, rocking the cradle
After a string of cinematic misfires, De Mornay
hit the reset button on her career.
The actress kicked off the 90s with a small-screen
role as a bomber pilot in HBO's Emmy-winning,
Cold War-tinged HBO original By Dawn's Early
Light.
The next year, in 1991, she found herself
at the top of the box office when Ron Howard
cast her in his smash hit firefighter drama
Backdraft.
While De Mornay's role is only a supporting
one, her skills on the big screen still showed.
It's a performance that must have made an
impression with her peers, particularly director
Curtis Hanson, who cast her as a villainous
would-be nanny in his 1992 thriller The Hand
That Rocks the Cradle.
De Mornay more than delivered the goods as
the psychologically-damaged character, and
this time found herself the lead in a blockbuster
hit that held the number one spot at the box
office for four straight weeks.
De Mornay spent the '90s coupling her acting
projects with producer credits, with work
including Never Talk To Strangers, The Winner,
and A Table For One.
De Mornay also made an appearance on the mid-'90s
revival of the popular anthology series The
Outer Limits, on which she earned her one
and only credit as a director.
Her episode, "The Conversion," premiered as
the 12th installment of the series, telling
a complex, violent story.
"The Conversion" follows a man fresh out of
prison and harboring a serious grudge against
his former employers — the sort of grudge
that drives him to pick up a gun and open
fire on his old office's Christmas party.
As one might expect with the sci-fi/fantasy
series, all is not what it appears to be,
with De Mornay playing a key role as a mysterious
woman who may or may not be pulling the strings
on the whole situation.
Well what were you thinking about, buying
a drink for someone you don't even know?"
"Maybe I feel like I know you."
Working behind the camera, she handled the
challenging material with style and grit,
delivering a violent, clever, character study
about mistakes and second chances.
She also got to direct her old Beauty and
the Beast co-star John Savage in the process.
Rebecca De Mornay's career continued to flourish
throughout the '90s, but 1997 saw the actor
take one of her biggest risks yet when she
landed the role of Wendy Torrance in the made-for-TV
miniseries adaptation of Stephen King's The
Shining.
The story had already been adapted by Stanley
Kubrick almost two decades prior, with iconic
performances from Jack Nicholson and Shelley
Duvall.
With the original being regarded by many as
one of the best horror movies ever made, the
stakes were high for the three-part miniseries,
with comparisons to the classic first adaptation
being inevitable.
King, being no fan of Kubrick's adaptation,
took on the task of scripting the episodes
himself, resulting in a four-and-a-half-hour
adaptation that's as faithful to his novel
as possible — for better or for worse.
As for De Mornay and her on-screen husband,
Steven Weber, each finds a way to make the
characters their own, helping make their version
of The Shining a respectable effort that has
Stephen King's seal of approval.
After finding some genuine small-screen success
with the Emmy-nominated adaptation of The
Shining, De Mornay wasted little time booking
her next TV gig.
She ended up landing on one of the greatest
and longest-running series ever produced:
ER.
De Mornay made her debut in the first episode
of the series' sixth season, playing Elaine
Nichols, a wealthy seductress in a relationship
with Noah Wyle's Dr. Carter, with the twist
being that her character is also the recently-divorced
ex-wife of Carter's cousin.
"What was it you said?
'I'll be thinking of you tonight?'"
"I guess I meant it."
Throughout De Mornay's arc, the pair face
numerous challenges, including the obvious
family turmoil, their dramatic age difference,
and eventually a breast cancer storyline that
sees Carter trying to be supportive as Elaine
endures a mastectomy.
Eventually, the couple ends things with Elaine
running off to Europe to start anew, and Carter
staying in Chicago to continue saving lives.
Though De Mornay's role lasted just five episodes,
it remains one of the series' more memorable
guest appearances.
Though she's had serious successes on the
small screen, De Mornay has always done her
best work in feature films.
A shrewd bit of casting gave De Mornay a chance
to showcase the full range of her talents
when she played the role of an aging TV star
with a nasty streak in James Mangold's psychological
thriller Identity.
Conceived as an Agatha Christie-style whodunnit,
the movie is an ensemble piece following a
group of strangers being stalked by a murderer
in a seedy, isolated motel.
At the same time, the movie focuses on the
testimony of a potentially schizophrenic death
row inmate, whose mind may hold the key to
the gruesome mystery at hand.
Needless to say, there's a lot to unpack with
Identity as the film twists and turns to an
unexpected conclusion.
Over 15 years after its release, the movie
remains a uniquely satisfying mindbender,
that just so happens to feature one of the
best performances of Rebecca De Mornay's career.
Though she was blessed with leading lady looks
and acting chops to match, De Mornay has never
been one to shy away from playing compelling
supporting characters in bigger movies.
More often than not, she's made the most of
these minor roles, bringing rich personalities
to even the most marginal of characters.
Of her supporting turns, few were more memorable
— or more brief — than her role as a vindictive
divorcee in the opening moments of 2005's
outlandish comedy Wedding Crashers.
She's the woman who traded barbs with Dwight
Yoakam as one half of a soon-to-be-divorced
couple, who are forced to remember the good
times by Vince Vaughn and Owen Wilson's divorce
mediators.
Though the scene clocks in at just about three
and a half minutes, it serves as a perfect
tone-setter for the raucous action that follows,
all mostly thanks to De Mornay.
You SHUT your mouth when you're talking to
me."
Now more than four decades into her career,
De Mornay's professional life has continued
to flourish.
Like many former "it girls" and young movie
icons who came up exploiting their sex appeal,
De Mornay has made a second career of sorts
out of playing moms on screen.
In the last 15 years alone, she's played a
parental role in over a dozen projects on
screens both big and small, including turns
on John From Cincinnati, American Reunion,
Mother's Day, American Venus, and Hatfields
& McCoys, all while playing real-life mom
to two daughters of her own.
Of course, De Mornay's most memorable turn
as a fictitious mother has been as Dorothy
Walker, the fame-hungry woman whose daughter
is Trish "Patsy" Walker on Netflix's Jessica
Jones.
Like many of her supporting turns over the
years, De Mornay brings a hefty dose of humanity
to the role, helping make a complex human
being out of what might otherwise have been
a shrill, patently unlikable character.
"Taking you in was the worst decision of my
life."
"Thanks, Mom."
As Rebecca De Mornay nears her 60th birthday,
it's clear that the acclaimed actor has no
intention of slowing down, having recently
completed a two-episode arc on Fox's Lucifer
and appearing in 2018's family drama Periphery.
As for what lies ahead, we expect to see De
Mornay reprise her role as Dorothy Walker
in the third season of Jessica Jones.
She's also slated to play a key role in the
Nick Cannon-directed women's basketball drama
She Ball.
From there, the sky seems to be the limit
for the gifted career performer.
One thing we know for sure is that she seems
primed to continue playing strong, intelligent,
complex women on TV shows and movies for years
to come.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.